for Carol keeping her home warm this
winter has been difficult she's had to
rely on a warm bank at her local
community library that's where we first
met and when I'm here it's like
everything disappears
I don't have to worry about anything
I've forgot until five of them here it's
lovely and then when I go home I know
it's bedtime
because then I have to take my my
medication tonight
then I go to bed because what else is
there it's going to be freezing though
miles away in Ireland 10 year old Nathan
had been watching our report with his
mother lavender he was moved to tears
and eager to help so Nathan are you
excited about meeting I'm very very
excited I'm I'm overjoyed and now the
Kellogg balls and Carol finally catch up
hi Carol Hi how are you I'm good
actually I'm much better today yeah so
tell me how
you were worried for me what had
happened was Ireland just had this whole
one week of ice
and it was like biting cold and he was
sick
so he had just gone through the whole
dose of steroids and all that because of
the cold so what just came to his mind
was like what could happen to this lady
I was worried for you because I saw you
that in the cold if you were like that I
don't know what could have happened so I
really wanted to donate to help you to
get out of the cold and also to be able
to have a warm house
I don't really want to take your savings
I don't think I would that would sit
comfortably with me but I really am
appreciated
of of your kind thoughts
for me I think you've helped me
emotionally that you really touched my
heart you really have you've touched my
heart
I could be more happier now
I feel like I've got an adopted son
we should definitely keep in touch yes
no problem no problem give me a smile
give me a smile Nate that's better you
look pretty when you have a smile
yeah a smile is a very good thing to
have
and don't lose it okay and don't worry
about me don't worry about me I'll be
okay they may be Generations apart but
one thing's for certain Nathan's kind
gesture has left more of an impact than
he could have ever imagined I shizarhid
Sky News